mara cedar you've got what it takes to
be the official stone of the United
States getting those groceries pushing
those buggies doing what you do he's
gotta get those groceries empty on
plates
get those groceries harris-teeter there
is to your haters under Harris Teeter
Harris Teeter Harris Teeter Harris under
Harris to your hair do this only one
place to go when you gotta get your
brochure Harris Teeter if got everything
you want even but you don't want okay
Harris Teeter shooter cookies Oh Harris
either represent eco States world
domination of a tea in the United States
have a cedar
Oh Harris eaters
yesterday keep it up keep it up keep it
up keep it up it's great okay that's
good good
you